Let's install the new Google Cloud Client Libraries for .NET
Google Cloud libraries are published as NuGet packages to integrate
with Google Cloud services such as BigQuery, Pub/Sub and
Cloud Storage. First, let's install Google Cloud SDK for Windows.
Before we can use these libraries
We need to install Google Cloud SDK for Windows
Setup authentication using gcloud auth login command
Now, let's go to Visual Studio and create a console
application to talk to Cloud Storage as an example
Once the project is created, right click on references and
manage NuGet packages. Make sure include pre-release
is selected.
Search for
Google.Storage.V1
for Cloud Storage and install
NuGet pulls down the package along with its dependencies
Now, you're ready to use it in your application to talk to Cloud Storage
For more information, see the links in the description